I mean that's probably one of the things that made them sick.
What was your take on it?
I mean you probably already talked about,
so sorry if you did,
but uh,
with that whole Connor in New York thing,
yeah,
pretty fucking crazy.
Um,
there's a whole story behind it and the story behind it is that Artem low Bob,
who is one of 'em Connor stable mates had an issue with Khabib.
Norma Madoff,
cause he said something in an interview that can be pulled out of fights.
Then the Conners,
the real,
real fighter and then Khabib's a coward so it could be found him and kind of
smacked him a little,
said you call me a coward motherfucker.
Like that kind of shit.
And there's a video of him saying it to him,
talking to him in Russian and Connor saw that video and flew from Ireland with a
bunch of fucking gangsters all the way to New York to crazy.
Yeah.
There might've been some substances involved.
Not good though.
No.
I mean he might,
he literally might wind up wind up in jail.
It's entirely possible that New York's going to prosecute him.
I mean that was like a salt.
He threw a dolly at a car.
People get their eyes cut and their face cut glass shatter.
I,
yeah.
Yeah.
And luckily it wasn't,
I mean I don't want to say it's any better that men get cut,
but imagine if he did it to rose.
Nama.
Eunice,
she's beautiful little 24 year old girl who's a world champion would have,
she got cut by the glass.
What if he ruined her career?
Like what if she never got to fight again with the glass?
Cut Her eye and we lost rose and that would have been the day of or day before a
fight today.
Before fine.
She,
she thought about pulling out of the fight.
She was so distraught by the whole event that she thought really pulling out.
Yeah.
Cause she was on that bus.
Yeah,
yeah.
Definitely not going to get him.
I guess I don't know it,
but then in a way it does.
I know there's people who are talking about,
oh this is all coordinated planned like teams on your rent,
Preston.
Yeah.
I mean you can definitely see how how it could be.
It's not,
it doesn't,
but I mean,
yeah,
it's just not,
but it's not going to,
is it going to lower his draw?
Probably not know it's going to,
he's going to be even bigger than ever.
That's what I'm saying.
So when he actually does fight Khabib,
if those two do fight,
if let's say,
let's say they solve everything civilly,
meaning Connor pays everybody off paste.
Kassoff pays Ray Borg off pays up emotional duress to anyone who sues him.
That was on the bus pay some sort of a fine to the state in New York.
That's pretty significant.
Gives up a few million dollars for sure.
Right Hook.
Then they put the fight together.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta be giant.
Maybe that would be the rule
guy.
Mcgregor was co come back.
Fight is already being mooted as what does that mean as the biggest record
breaker in UFC history?
I've never seen that word.
Mooted have you ever seen it?
I think mean it's touted it,
but I've seen it either the biggest record breaker in UFC history.
Yeah,
I will be if he fights Khabib.
Yeah.
Experts are predicting.
He'll be back in the octagon within a year.
Okay.
I'd say a year from now,
that's not like a much of a stretch.
That's a crazy prediction is six to 12 months,
so I just saw and maybe 81,000 seat stadium in Moscow.
That's what they're going to do potentially.
I mean,
it's not signed,
obviously,
but that's what this article is.
You know,
we're,
we're going to be right here watching it right here,
watching that shit on that TV.
It's going to be awesome.
We're going to be an American on American soil,
drinking Budweiser,
drinking American beer,
maybe some Sam Adams something American.
I'm not going to Russia not going come to me and Russia because Russia.